Oh
I have no idea what King cake is but I
assume it's luxurious as [ __ ]
it's named after a king thought we were
eating like king crab cakes I thought
there was crab here it's like a cake
shaped like a baby any teach kid gets a
piece and the kid the kid that finds the
King inside of it like a game
fiddle-dee-dee it's giving birth listen
oh my god here she comes
oh my god it's a bully there's a naked
toddler who's trying to get a hug or not
it was pregnant oh my god why not you is
that please how it goes with this does
this make me the mother except don't
talk about mijita near Jesus's crotch
holy [ __ ] - sugary New Orleans people
don't [ __ ] around because this is
literally icing and sugar on top just go
same a little heavy it's like a sugar
scrub while you're eating it it tastes
like a congealed Cinnabon sprinkled with
a pound and a half of sugar in every
bite the whole variant of texture and
almost dying I don't know how we're just
getting past it great cake I do feel
like we've experienced a little bit of
Monica I think if I go to New Orleans
for Mardi Gras I'm gonna be more excited
about the cake than the boobs my first
rule as king of this cake is that I get
to eat the rest of the cake and I get
pancakes